[Musica]
Buonasera mi trovo su questo splendido
palcoscenico a parlarvi di connessione e
ho deciso di farlo in un modo un po'
insolito vorrei trattare con voi un
argomento scomodo Ma che io ritengo
molto attuale
vi parlerò della possibilità di rimanere
connessi nell'abbandono
vi starete domandando perché un manager
delle telecomunicazioni ha deciso di non
parlare di connessioni di reti i cavi o
di 5G E beh Secondo me questa è la parte
scocciante del mio lavoro la parte più
divertente è che io lavoro con i ragazzi
ne ho 450 a Tirana 26 anni per lo più ne
ho 150 in Italia
trentenni e insegno all'università a
giovani di 19 20 21 anni e quello che
provo a fare quotidianamente e formare
questi ragazzi motivarli affinché loro
nelle difficoltà trovino le risorse per
trasformare quegli eventi in opportunità
perché è un po' quello che è successo a
me a causa di un forte dolore io sono
riuscito a trovare le mie connessioni
diciamo l'abbandono è stata per me
l'opportunità
a dispetto dell'interconnessione e
dell'iperconnettività dei nostri giorni
quali social network mezzi di trasporto
ultrà veloci videocall zoom teams questa
sindrome è un argomento sempre più
frequente e comune andiamo nel metaverso
lo facciamo con amici incontriamo di
nuove persone conosciamo nuove persone
nei giochi virtuali ci vediamo chattiamo
ci sentiamo con persone dall'altra parte
dell'emisfero e se le vogliamo andare a
trovare ci mettiamo anche poche ore ma
le statistiche Tra l'altro facilmente
reperibili a chiunque anche su internet
ci dicono che ci sentiamo sempre più
soli e ricorriamo sempre di più all'uso
di ansiolitici e psicofarmaci
domanda a voi pubblico quanti si sono
sentiti nella loro vita almeno una volta
abbandonati
da un familiare
da un amico
da un collega
dal partner
vedo le vostre mani alzarsi
siamo abbastanza no E quanti si sono
sentiti così a causa di un tradimento
o di un lutto
siamo tanti che succede perché noi
Proviamo questo sentimento perché si
immergiamo in questo stato d'animo che
fondamentalmente sentiamo di aver perso
connessione con l'altra persona e cosa
facciamo l'essere umano Cosa fa scappa
scappa perché non vuole provare dolore
come fa fisicamente in posti nuovi o
mentalmente si rifugia chi nello sport
Chi nel lavoro
chi nelle serie TV social network
c'è Addirittura chi lo fa con il cibo
chi Con il sesso o purtroppo chi Con la
droga o con l'alcol
e
diciamo l'ho fatto anche io anche io
sono scappato e molto lontano e anche io
ho iniziato a riempire la vita in
maniera frenetica quasi compulsiva di
attività pur di non riflettere
motivo per cui voglio partire proprio
dalla mia storia da piccolo ero un
bambino estremamente competitivo io
vivevo tutto come una sfida di fronte a
chi mi diceva cosa dovevo fare io mi
mettevo sulla difensiva e aspettavo il
momento per fare un dispetto ero un
bimbo un po' anarchico non riconoscevo
l'autorità ero ribelle e
l'esatto frutto di genitori divorziati
che aveva visto la mamma soffrire e il
padre di farsi una vita con un altro
figlio
non mi piaceva stare a casa a giocare ai
videogiochi non mi piace a studiare a
casa da soli io preferisco stare in
compagnia andare al parco a giocare con
gli altri bimbi non mi piacevano gli
sport singolari il tennis il nuoto
pensate che mi scrivevano puntualmente a
nuoto Io puntualmente quando devo andare
a nuoto mi facevo venire la febbre io
preferivo il calcetto il basket la
pallavolo
e però la mia vita era movimentata a me
piaceva molto stare in compagnia ed era
ed era piena
Ma questa a 16 anni cambio
cambio perché perché mia mamma si ammalò
di cancro al seno il cancro poi dopo si
estese ai polmoni alle ossa al cervello
e giù di lì e la mia nuova sfida diventò
fare la guarire questa battaglia la
combattiamo tutti i giorni tantissimi
medici in giro per l'Italia tantissime
curiosità
tantissime notti svegli per contrastare
gli effetti collaterali delle
chemioterapie e io pensavo di aver fatto
tanto per salvare mia mamma eh però dopo
quattro anni non ce la finisci la
battaglia non la perdemmo ma per demmo e
Io rimasi solo
solo è molto arrabbiato molto arrabbiato
perché pensavo di non meritarlo non era
giusto
Eh ma insieme era quella grande
solitudine inizio davvero il mio
isolamento se non c'era più lei nessuno
era più meritevole di starmi vicino non
facevo più avvicinare nessuno
e oltre a questi se lamento iniziavano
le forti sensi di colpa adesso Sfido
chiunque di voi a dirmi che non è così
dopo un fallimento dopo una perdita ci
diamo le colpe no
e se avessimo fatto di più
se avessimo ascoltato di più
e se in quell'occasione non ci fossimo
comportati in quel modo era un po' le
domande che mi facevo anche io e se
fossi stato più tempo con mia mamma e se
fosse andato da un altro medico e se
avessi studiato di più quando lei era in
vita e se se sarebbe successo lo stesso
decisi così di andarmene di partire essi
Qual è il posto più lontano in assoluto
Ma dai le mie referenze all'università
del posto e fece un po' come Merlino e
la spada nella roccia mi trasferiamo uno
Lulù né a studiare lì Diciamo me lo
Scelsi anche abbastanza bene Non posso
non noioso posso bello e da quel momento
iniziai anche a lavorare e studiare
tantissimo per me l'importante era
andarmene lontanissimo perché ero
convinto che il dolore lì non mi avrebbe
raggiunto
e soprattutto impegnare la mia vita in
maniera compulsiva affinché non avrei
mai potuto fare i conti con me stesso
come ho detto si scappa si scappa
lontano ci si riempie la vita di cose
pur di non pensare io feci tutte e due
le cose e ma vi dico e ve lo dico oggi a
distanza di 10 anni e a distanza di 13
anni io sono anche rientrato a casa che
da tutto questo mio percorso da tutto
questo mio scappare da tutto quel fare e
ancora oggi sto raccogliendo i frutti
sono tornato migliore vi spiego perché
mi trova dall'altra parte il mondo
persone diversissime da me in termini di
valori cultura
abitudini religione ma simile a me in
termini di vissuto ero partito convinto
che ero l'unico ad avere una ferita
aperta che nessuno mi avrebbe mai potuto
capire Nessuno mi capiva Emma
confrontandomi con le persone io mi
rendevo sempre più conto che di gente
con una cicatrice cicatrice importante
ce n'è tantissima
iniziava a dire non c'è più il solo
mi ero spezzato è vero Ma quanti noi si
sono spezzati qua dentro per tantissimi
anni mi hanno criticato hanno detto che
io ero attratto da persone tormentate da
persone tristi e che la colpa era mia
Ma quelle occasioni erano per me gli
unici momenti in cui io non provavo
vergogna in cui potevo raccontarmi non
provo imbarazzo a parlare la mia storia
il dolore circolava liberamente e
sentivo che fare questa roba mi faceva
stare meglio ed era anche utile agli
altri Basta semplicemente dirci Ti
capisco Ci sono passato anche io in un
certo senso le persone che hanno vissuto
importante si riconoscono si incontrano
c'è una connessione speciale tra di noi
forse una sensibilità differente come vi
dicevo Sì mi ero spezzato è vero
però ero partito convinto di essere
l'unico ad essersi spezzato
e invece non era così
non era così e me ne rendevo sempre più
conto
io per tanti anni ho cercato mia mamma
nei sogni e l'orizzonte in chiesa ma non
la sentivo non c'era più connessione con
lei perché ero troppo arrabbiato con il
tempo ho chiesto aiuto Ho chiesto a un
professionista Anzi a vari
professionisti di aiutarmi perché da
solo non riuscivo a liberarmi tutta
quella angoscia di quel peso che portavo
dentro e questa ha fatto sì che io mi
iniziasse a perdonare
oggi non ho più sensi di colpa per non
aver salvato mia mamma ero troppo
piccolo per l'età che avevo mi sono
perdonato non ho più sensi di colpa per
aver trattato male le persone che in
quel momento mi tendevano una mano
non lo potevo capire in quel momento mi
sono perdonato
se anche voi avete commesso i miei
stessi errori Perdonatemi
può essere che avesse potuto fare di più
sì e quindi
sareste potuti Non scappare si può
essere e quindi siete anche tornati
Ognuno di noi deve trovare il suo click
per perdonarsi
rialzarsi e se ne ha bisogno chiederà
aiuto Che cos'è questo Click
prendiamo come esempio Ischia
Usiamo questo parallelismo per me Ischia
è un'isola
che mi sarà finalmente a cuore perché io
ci venivo da piccolino a fare la vacanza
e mancavo da 30 anni su quest'isola
ischia novembre a causa di un forte
nubrifragio si è spezzata Tra l'altro
non era neanche la prima volta eh
ha sofferto tanto tantissime famiglie
sono state sfollate tantissimi palazzi
sono stati distrutti
tante vittime e Ischia però ha urlato il
suo dolore e ha chiesto aiuto
e in tantissimi hanno risposto presente
come con donazioni
o venendo sul territorio a scalare nel
fango gli scatti è rialzata ed è
quest'isola fantastica di cui oggi noi
stiamo ammirando i colori e ne sentiamo
ancora il profumo ha chiesto aiuto e ce
l'ha fatta
per tanti anni ho provato vergogna mi
sentivo inadatto
tendevo a non accettare la mia sindrome
dell'abbandono e quello che mi sento di
dirvi è questo se anche voi vi siete
sentiti come me
non pensate di essere inadatti se anche
voi come me da solo non ce l'ha sentita
di non riuscircela fare Non ce l'avete
fatta chiedete aiuto alzate una mano
Considerate che io ora ho una compagna
fantastica la migliore che si possa
desiderare non so neanche se la merito
lei è nella mia vita da sempre Sembra
uno scherzo siamo nati nello stesso
giorno lo stesso mese stesso anno nello
stesso ospedale
è vero
e però non la vedevo
ho una famiglia vera
che crede in valori importanti che è
sempre stata lì disposta ad amarmi
voleva solo l'opportunità di farlo Eh ma
io la rinnegavo
o degli amici veri relazioni forti gente
buona che mi avrebbero solo voluto fare
compagnia ma io li scacciavo
Oggi io sono connesso con me stesso
perché mi sono perdonato e ho chiesto
aiuto sono connesso con gli altri perché
non sono più arrabbiato ho smesso di
isolarmi e sono connesso anche con chi
non c'è più perché non ho più sensi di
colpa
perché nel dolore con coraggio tutti
quanti dobbiamo trovare la forza di dire
mi sono spezzato ma non sono il solo
Ricordatevi noi non siamo soli e se
stiamo perdendo la bussola chiediamo
aiuto rimanete connessi
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]